dans ce club de judo après des mois
d'interruption c'est l'heure du retour
sur les tatamis avec pour cette saison
de nouveaux réflexes à prendre quand on
monte sur le tapis vous avez vu on a
tous l'avènement passer un petit peu de
gel hydroalcoolique sur les pieds mais à
la clé le plaisir de retrouver leur
sport préféré à combattre jouer koné
coronavirus parfois le montre l uimm qui
peut échouer tapis chez moi difficile
dans un sport de combat d'éviter les
contacts
alors les enfants travaillent en petits
groupes pour limiter les échanges et le
club se prépare à devoir adopter de
nouvelles préconisations en cours de
saison on est en permanence sur
l'adaptation est effectivement ça va
modifier
tout du moins au début beaucoup notre
contenu et on va voir une perte de temps
très très importante mais bon il vaut
mieux perdre du temps et faire les
choses bien plutôt que de vouloir se
précipiter ne pas perdre de temps puis
faire n'importe quoi du côté de lui
sonne c'est aussi la rentrée pour
l'école de rugby
cette année les enfants doivent arriver
déjà changé car les vestiaires sont
fermés c'est plutôt logique chez moi je
vais gagner du temps après les
entraînements dont six à être plus vite
dans la voiture on sera partis prise de
risque c'est vrai que ça pénalise
aujourd'hui alors moins parce qu'il ya
soleil mais c'est vrai qu'on attend en
tout cas les prochaines mesures pour
pouvoir et ouvrir ses vestiaires et pour
pouvoir accueillir les enfants dans de
meilleures conditions
le club applique les protocoles définis
par la fédération masques pour les
éducateurs et les parents gourdes aux
individuels et des infections des
ballons et de tout ce qui passe de main
en main c'est compliqué on va nettoyer
le matériel à chaque fin de séance pour
sécuriser au maximum pour c'est que les
enfants peut être vecteur du virus
un retour particulier sur les terrains
de sport en espérant que cette fois la
saison puisse aller jusqu'à son terme